that said i mean i love the term mate
poaching by the way i believe here in
texas mate poaching is officially
illegal so
one of my favorite songs by hendricks is
hey joe
um
hey joe where you going with that gun in
your hand yeah
and
yeah i actually i always wanted to play
that song but i get uh
i start to think about guns and so on i
think it's supposed to capture
a feeling it's not actual violence it's
saying i'm gonna shoot my old lady i
caught her messing around with another
man
that's uh
that's a blues type of feeling like of
anger
of um i guess from mate poaching
for uh mate switching performed by the
partner and then the uh the frustration
and the anger that's resulting that i
always wondered why the violence
is directed towards the partner versus
the person who did the yeah it's
the other male tends to be evenly split
um so sometimes and that's i mean um
men especially uh when someone poaches
on their mate they have homicidal
fantasies
which
well equally towards the mate poacher
yeah but but he but equally split so so
it's uh
um
i think the the non-lethal violence uh
tends to be more directed toward the
mate because it's it's and this is a
horrible thing of male sexual psychology
but i think part of the violence is
functional
in the sense that it's designed to
keep a mate and prevent her from
engaging in anything with um
with other with other potential mate
poachers
but um
uh but people do uh it's so even i mean
it says it goes back uh
like to the french law where they had
the
so-called crime of passion so if the
husband walked in and found
his wife
having sex with some other guy in bed
and shot him that was viewed as a crime
of passion it's still not legal but you
kind of get a discount
yeah uh for it whereas if he if he goes
home thinks about it for a while then
gets the gun comes back then that's
premeditated murder
yeah
see to me i guess everybody's different
to me i have zero
anger towards the partner on that
situation to me because that's
definitive proof
of disability so like why what's the
what's the function of the anger there
no to me
uh
all of my anger is towards the the guy
the poacher right because
some of it has to do probably with the
status establishing
like it's uh what was the term you use
the
formidability yeah formidability
assessment assessment and i'm like wait
wait wait did you just say you're more
formidable than me
in this situation i want to re-establish
at least in my own mind the
formidability
and
and that seems to be
i guess we're all different but maybe
because i roll around with guys a lot
like grappling wrestling all that kind
of stuff to me to establish status it's
competing with other males not with the
female because that that's a break of
loyalty
like why do what's this what's the point
of anger at this point that's just
betrayal well except that a lot of it uh
a lot of the mate poaching is is
discovered or cues to make pushings are
discovered before
the consummation of the act so it might
be just like the emotional cheating
leader or of
mile flirtation
sure you know uh things like that and so
the violence is is um
designed to head off the threat before
it becomes real
boy aren't human relations especially
romantic ones complicated
so uh barely
but that's what makes them so
fascinating to study and so fun yes
exactly from a science perspective and
to study from within sort of uh
uh what's like richard rangham with the
champs like um you know
be in it
study from the end of one perspective